ich habe auch ein thema mitgebracht was
mich bewegt aber was mich ehrlich gesagt
traurig macht denn es gibt es kamen neue
zahlen und letztes jahr ist sind sie
illegalen drogen gab es ein anstieg von
13 prozent der todesfälle also 13
prozent mehr menschen sind letztes jahr
in deutschland an dem konsum von
illegalen drogen gestorben ich sehe das
thema viel zu selten in der deutschen
medienlandschaft aktuell weil wir müssen
auch darüber reden dessen schattenseiten
der korona politik und auch der korona
pandemie 13 prozent mehr toten illegalen
drogen das heißt nicht dass ich wie
manche parteien dass er gerne wollen
eine libelle liberalisierung zum
beispiel von cannabis wird das will ich
wahrlich nicht aber ich möchte dass wir
heute darüber reden warum so wenig
darüber berichtet wird warum wir da
nicht stärker eingreifen weil und das
fand ich besonders erschreckend durch
die korona pandemie und durch die
regularien wurden vor allem die sucht
plätze immer immer schwerer für süchtige
zu finden und auch dass sie durchgeführt
werden konnten der drogenkonsum dem muss
ein ende gesetzt werden der illegalen
drogen vor allem darf er nicht noch
weiter ansteigen was die todesfälle
betrifft 13 prozent und damit guten
abend ich
finde das super dass wir heute über der
politik sprechen was gesagt wir haben
viel zu wenig im wahlkampf darüber
gesprochen ich glaube das liegt auch so
ein bisschen daran dass politiker
vielleicht bei diesem thema auch ein
bisschen vorsichtiger sind weil es kann
sehr kontrovers geben es gibt sehr viele
missverständnisse in der frage und ich
bin genauso wie du traurig darüber dass
es diesen anstieg gibt weil die korona
pandemie und das sehen wir nicht nur an
der kennzahl sondern ein ganz vielen
anderen psychische erkrankungen
wirtschaftliche nöte bildungs
ungerechtigkeiten wir können ganz vielen
messen welche auswirkungen die pandemie
hat was wir sehr häufig während corona
maßnahmen zu wenig diskutiert haben
meiner ansicht nach und deswegen müssen
wir das auch nach analysieren nach
bewährten und was daraus erfolgt und wir
suchtkranken helfen können dass die
direkten therapieplatz beispielsweise
kriegen ich teil nur nicht ganz deiner
meinung und das weißt du auch dass
vielleicht mehr liberalität durchaus
auch eine antwort da sein kann ich
möchte dass am bereich cannabis auch
gerne ins teilt führen beispiel bei
einem schwarzmarkt kann der dealer
cannabis mit haarspray strecken super
gesundheitsschädlich wenn ich das
rauchen kann ich die hier geschehen es
gibt keine qualitätsstandards
beispielsweise auf dem schwarzmarkt das
ist fast der raubtierkapitalismus ja da
geht nur dass man möglichst viel geld
macht und als liberaler sage ich nicht
möchte einen kontrollierten
ordnungsrahmen ein staat ihr könnt ihr
kontrollierte freigabe gemacht nur an
volljährige personen in die zensierten
fachgeschäften apotheken coffeeshops wir
kennen es aus den niederlande mit
qualitätsstandard weil dadurch sogar der
effekt entsteht das nur möglich bei
konsum weniger
gesundheitsschädigend quasi drucker auf
rezept balkan hat es sogar gibt es ja
schon früher nicht mal auf rezept
sondern auf kauf kann auch niederlande
sind ja auch jetzt nicht so unbedingt
das beste beispiel was das thema auch
drogentote angeht also ich sehe die
position die sie gemacht haben steht ja
auch im fdp-wahlprogramm drin aber wenn
ich mir auch die begründung anschaue
warum das so kommen soll dann muss ich
doch sagen bin ich eigentlich ehrlich
gesagt sehr erstaunt denn die freigabe
von drogen oder drogenfrei zu gehen weil
man sagt dann legalisiert man auch und
ohnehin gibt es dann keine
bagatelldelikte mir das ein
armutszeugnis eigentlich für den staat
vergibt damit ja auch zu dass er sagt
ich bin überfordert die
drogenkriminalität in griff zu kriegen
also das gegenteil glaube ich was ein
liberaler möchten sollte eigentlich der
brauch eigentlich ein staat der einen
ordnungsrahmen setzt und diesem
ordnungsrahmen auch ordentlich handeln
kann und deswegen bin ich da komplett
anderer meinung als sie sind dabei kann
er bestimmt ist nicht bei den
niederländischen zahlen dass es da
besonders viele drogentote geht bei
cannabis ist ja die drogentoten anzahl
auch gar nicht
genau sich mal eben ganz kurz
beispringen cannabis ist aber eine
einstiegsdroge und das ist schon so dass
leute erstmal mit cannabis zu gehen und
dann sich dieser nach anderen sachen
werden das ist sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht was dazu
geführt hat dass das nicht
wissenschaftliche evidenz ist dass man
nicht cannabis konsumiert habe direkt
andere drogen konsumieren dieser
trugschluss der letzte nicht sein dass
ein gerade wände ist keine kontrolle
gibt bei den qualitätsstandards
beispielsweise um und da möchte ich
vielleicht noch um einen weiteren punkt
machen bei der liberalisierung die da
auch dann den vorteil hat glaube ich
einfach hat das ist eine staatliche
kontrolle gibt weil die frage ist ja für
mich gibt zwei arten von konsumenten der
eine konsument entscheidet 3 über seinen
körper und kann mit der sucht umgehen
oder hat gar keine sucht man soll erst
frei entscheiden können seinen körper
seine entscheidung die anderer fall ist
jemand wird abhängig kann nicht mehr
frei über seinen körper entscheiden und
ein feld in einer sucht und da würde ich
sagen ich weiß nicht ob als liberaler
der spieler das recht das richtige
mittel ist oder ob wir suchtkranken
durch therapie hilfe leisten kann also
ich habe immer gedacht einen kranken
menschen helfen wir als staat und nicht
bestrafen wir mit dem strafrecht und ich
glaube der staat hat doch auch was
besseres zu tun als harmlose kiffer und
unserer justiz zu verfolgen unsere
polizisten haben doch auch was besseres
zu tun als irgendwelche jugendliche
aufzugreifen akten zu führen und dann
wieder fallen zu lassen ich habe
viel mehr
vielmehr psychosen aus cannabis löst
natürlich diese aktuelle corona politik
aus wir haben ja mit dem eigentlich
angefangen diese ansteigende
drogenkonsum ist ja ein direktes
krankheitssymptom dieser kranken völlig
überschießenden überbordenden
staatlichen freiheitsberaubung politik
die gegenwärtig überhaupt nicht mehr
legitimiert ist wie sie in keine vollen
spitäler wie sie ihn zurück gehen die
zahlen aber die politik hat sich in die
macht verliebt sie finden diesen control
freak ansatz dass sie die leute
einsperren können dass sie sie bevor nun
dann können in der schweiz noch
schlimmer als in deutschland das ist
genau die voraussetzung die dazu führt
dass leute zu mehr drogen greift wie
seen in der schweiz aber auch in
deutschland einen massiven anstieg bei
auch traumatisierten kindern wie
diskutieren völlig durchgeknallt über
einen masken pflicht in den schulen wir
diskutieren darüber dass zweifach
geimpfte dreifach geimpfte mit masken
rumlaufen müssen also hier hat der staat
komplett seine grenzen überschritten und
hier wünschte ich mir von den liberalen
einen viel entschlossenen gegen wir
gegen diese massive staatliche
freiheitsberaubung politik und die
drogengeschichte ist im grunde einfach
ein eine nebenwirkung eine tragische
eine schlechte eine schlimme
nebenwirkungen einer corona politik wo
paul ronzheimer habe ich heute auf bild
live sehr richtig gesagt hat wie lange
wollen sie das noch machen herz machen
wir es das noch jahrzehntelang also hier
müssen wir aufhören wir müssen zurück zu
einem vernünftigen rechtsstaat zu einem
freiheitlichen leben weil das was wir
jetzt machen das ist ungesund das ist
krank das ist machtmissbrauch der
behörden ich glaube es hat sich eine
klare antwort darauf gegeben auf diese
frage und hat sich da nicht darum
gedrückt aber noch mal zu ihrem punkt
der drogen freigabe
cannabis ja das ist meine frage dass ich
ja auch wir hin dass nicht mit thesen
überfrachten aber meine frage wo fangen
sie an wo hören sie auf sie haben den
gewinnsprung erklärt und gesagt dass der
staat auch dann partizipieren kann das
könnt ihr natürlich umso mehr wenn man
härtere drogen wo der gewinnsprung noch
höher ist natürlich auch da in ihrem
paket inkludieren wurde also auch koks
auf staatskosten oder heroin was jetzt
zum teil substituiert wird und auch an
schwerst wichtige gegeben wird also wo
fängt man an ihrer meinung nach würde
mich interessieren wo hört man auf und
will ihnen da auch nichts drin aber
diese dieser satz ja therapien müsste es
geben das hören wir doch schon seit 40
jahren das ist doch recht wenig als in
amerika wunderbar dann wünsche ich ihnen
alles gute dass sie diese verhältnisse
ändern und nicht nur hier ich wenig
sagen kluge sprüche machen müssen aber
auch dass das daran appellieren dass es
so kommt die realität sieht ja also aus
dass es viel zu wenig therapieplätze
gibt und das seit jahrzehnten auch dass
man sich hinzusetzen und zu sagen na ja
müsste man mehr therapieplätze geben und
ich bin dafür dass zu verlagern für eine
bestrafung in die therapie macht es sich
ein bisschen zu einfach ich glaube auch
der punkt und am ende wenn man lieber
denkt und das tue ich auch er musste ein
jeder mensch ein recht auf rausch haben
vollkommen richtig also jeder sollte
doch das konsumieren wollen was er will
der einzige punkt ist los er müsste man
auch selbst für die konsequenzen haften
und da geht das problemlos bespricht die
therapieplätze an sie sagen es gibt
nicht genügend die muss ja jemand
bezahlen und da werden die kosten des
des egoistischen handels oder des
eigenmächtigen handelns dass er korrekt
sein kann aus sicht des individuums aber
dann sozialisiert das heißt alle anderen
müssen dafür zahlen und da beginnt das
problem ich mache etwas was ungesund ist
was schlecht ist aber die anderen sollen
bitte die kosten übernehmen das geht
nicht
liberalismus begriff von von jan schäfer
nein und klar jeder soll das tun im
liberalsten sinne was er tun wird es
gibt aber auch menschen die werden in
die abhängigkeit geführt unter anderem
auch über einstiegsdrogen und ich weiß
natürlich es wird immer gesagt das wird
sicherlich die macher habe marihuana
haschisch ist es doch kein einziges
droge ist ja bescheuert aber natürlich
ist es in manchen fällen soll und die
frage ist das mit denen ist da hört die
freiheit nämlich auch die dann hin
verführt werden oder abhängig gemacht
werden ob diese individualistisch sagen
können ja ich möchte eine therapie oder
ich möchte gerne weitermachen also der
wirtschaftsnobelpreisträger milton
friedman sozusagen der das evangelium
des liberalismus
eine
ganz bedeutende figur natürlich des
liberalismus und der hat ja einen
berühmten aufsatz geschrieben in dem er
für die liberalisierung von drogen
argumentiert hat dies auch vor dem
hintergrund dass natürlich in den
vereinigten staaten in den in südamerika
aber wir sehen sie auch in afghanistan
in teilen asiens eine unglaublich
brutale mafia oder nehmen sie mexiko
eine mafia mit dieser
prohibition politik sich eine wirklich
goldene nase verdient und ganze staaten
zu kriminellen syndikaten umgebaut hat
weil diese
politik der repression und der
prohibition nicht funktioniert wir haben
es auch gesehen in der nur so in den
20er jahren als sie das alkohol verboten
haben das hat eine gigantische schwarze
industrie hochgebracht nun ist die po
ist der punkt natürlich der hätten wir
den mut kokain und heroin und auch diese
drogen zu liberalisieren ich bin auch
ein libero aber ich muss euch sagen
irgendetwas in mir zuckt zurück auch
wenn das quasi meine frau ist vermutlich
die sagt du wenn ich meine kinder
anschauen ich möchte sie nicht in so
einen drogen schon raus lassen aber ich
bin da ehrlich etwas unentschlossen weil
ich finde es gibt sehr sehr gute
argumente von sehr sehr klugen leuten
schien diese richtung argumentierten
[Musik]